max freed was one of the best pitchers
in baseball last year got off to a slow
start but he's beginning to round into
four
yeah he had three really horrible starts
to start this season but his last two
he's only given up a couple of runs
in 11 innings pitch lindor steps in
versus freed that's it in the air to
right field
ronaldo cunha coming in looks up into
that beautiful atlanta sky and makes the
catch
and one down cylinder flies to right and
here comes alonso
a little looper into shallow center and
that'll fall for a base set for alonso
and pete alonso was aboard with a one
out single
and that will bring up dom smith check
swing believe he went he did that's
strike three
couldn't hold back on that slider first
strike out of the ball game for freed
two down and there's kevin villard that
is hit hard out the left field ozuna
sprinting back
he's at the warning track throws up the
glove makes the catch of the wall
and that's out number three taiwan
walker will go to the mound and
generally that's been a really good
thing walker has been absolutely
fabulous so far he's three and one with
a 2.20 earned run average
coming off back-to-back terrific starts
on lacuna who has 21 career lead off
home runs most in the history of the
braves
yeah he's 23 years old he's in that lead
off spot
okunya first pitch swinging and he pops
one up into shallow center fargus got a
late start
first chance in his first game in the
big leagues and he puts it away
one pitch and one out here's freddie
freeman the reigning mvp
freeman gets one in the air to right
field and pilar is there
step in front of the warning track and
there are two out
two out nobody on last to the first
here's marcelo zuna right and better
he pops the first pitch up and lindor
waiting for it to come down with vr and
it'll be vr
to make the catch and a seven pitch
inning for taiwan walker
jonathan villard leads off in the second
against max free
round ball out to third diving stop by
reilly to the ground he goes
pops up low throw scooped of course by
freddie freeman
a dandy play for round number one here
in the top of the second and a good
scoop over there at first base by
freddie freeman following the diving
stop by austin reilly at the hot corner
here is jose peraza playing second base
for the match
off the end of the bat ramps off the
mound out to ozzy on a pair of twin hops
he throws over the first base and two
down
well max freed throws a couple of ground
ball outs to begin the top of the second
and tomas nito will be the batter lined
in the center field to base it
for neato in the midst of a two out base
runner and so now even though taiwan
walker is the pitcher he is batting
eighth today
and he'll be the batter now invert third
strike dropped the curveball over
as he registers his second strike out of
the ball game for the first time in his
life john eshway fargus is stepping into
a major league batter's box he's making
his major league debut tonight
got him swinging strike three slaughter
claims joe neshway fargus
i know the feeling kid went out here in
the third inning back to the top of the
order to francisco lindor
lunges and misses it gets by math as he
retrieves picks it up slings it to the
outside of the bag to secure the
strikeout
that's four strikeouts now for max free
and there's two up two down here in the
third
here's alonso slug out to riley and he
stabs it for round number three
they can't get it by austin a line drive
right into his glove and that's a one
two three time of the third inning 21
pitches for eight outs for taiwan walker
and now max freed
who is three for eight at the plate
hopper out to second and that's right on
through
and a base hit out of max freeze go
figure a pitcher will get the first hit
for the braves
max freed will bring acuna to the plate
with two outs that's his fourth hit
taiwan walker has hurt himself the last
two pitches he's looked
a little queasy something like in his
legs or something
i'm not sure and he docks the outside
corner strike three call
perfect pitch by walker to get a cuny
and in the inning
something is clearly bothering taiwan
walker taiwan walker is going to be
coming out of this game
as if the mets needed another situation
to deal with
meanwhile max freed back to the mound
for the braves as we go to the fourth
inning
got him swinging strike three use the
slider that go round
five strikeouts now for max free lunging
and missing his vr strike three when
after the curveball
six strikeouts here's peraza who
grounded out his first time up
and he'll be all for two once guillermo
heredia makes this catch
acuna joins him in right center it's
already in freed has
an easy fourth inning the new met
pitcher sean reid foley we got a report
on taiwan walker he left with left
side tightness and freed foley takes
over for him
marcelo zuma bats swinging the miss and
ozuna is down on strikes for the second
out
foley gets his first strike out of the
day two up two down as all bees will bat
and albies goes down on strikes and sean
reid foley with a very effective inning
coming on in surprise relief what does
the best pitcher in baseball do when
he's injured and he really has a lot of
time on his hands
well maybe he serves as a positioning
coach for uh the first baseman on the
other team
this is fun to watch okay that's a good
spot for him
he's going to buy i want a bunk that's
great
so walt weiss just lost his job
max freed is pitching like an ace again
for the braves his third straight
terrific start to this point
seven strikeouts two walks try
three a change up eight strikeouts now
for freed matching his season high
two out nobody on kevin keller coming up
it passed the third baseman riley and
down the line and pilar is going to get
an
extra base hit out of this jonathan
biard will try and get him home with two
out
hit on the ground tore the hole past
riley grab by swanson and they'll hold
the runner at third
and the mets have runners at the corners
with two outs and jose perazo to hit her
a dangerous pitch
[Applause]
and peraza shoots it right out of cunha
and the
inning is over that strand of pair in
the top of the sixth keeps this game
scoreless
max freed with six scoreless innings
under his belt this will be only the
seventh time in his career he's gone
beyond six innings
in a game it'll start with tomas nito
who
jeff rightly said has had the best at
bats against max free tonight
nito flies one out to right center over
toward the gap and it's going to land
for a base hit
nina on his way to second and he'll pull
in standing with a double
tomas nito as a lead off double bernito
it's his second head of the day
so now the braves are coming out to
check on max freed with
the trainer brian snitker's not going to
chance it max freid has to come
out of this game after facing one batter
in the seventh inning now
you see him sitting there talking to
travis starnow look he was close to
where he was coming out anyways
jacob webb is in atlanta's team era from
their bullpen
is the sixth worst in the major leagues
james mccann bats for sean reid foley
can lines it toward left base hit hits
down the line it goes to the corner
tomasz nito
rounds third and scores mccann comes
through and the mitts take a one-nothing
lead so dominic smith is going to head
to first
after an intentional walk and now kevin
pallar will have a chance
with the bases loaded and two outs hit
hit pilar
and it hit him in the head polar is down
and actually it hit pallar right in the
face his face is
busted up he is bleeding on the field
profusely
you could see the blood rushing out of
what seems to be the bridge of his nose
this is an awful scene well good to see
him able to get up and walk under his
own power but
that's a scary sight everybody in both
dugouts is shaken by this
they're doing some cleanup around home
plate to get the blood
soaked up i mean that was just a scary
moment for everybody
so a shaken jacob webb leaves the field
after hitting kevin pillar in the face
and down to second base
goes neato two men away and janeshway
fargus looking for his first big league
hit will be the batter
bloops one shallow right that'll fall
for a baseball
neato around third down to second base
goes
fargus he's got his first big league hit
in the midst of a three-nothing lead
the braves event just one base runner
through the first seven innings
and that was a hit by max freed in the
third one away
at austin riley coming up it weld a deep
right center field
this ball is blasted back to the wall
and the braves are on the board
austin riley with a home run to right
center field cuts the mets lead to three
to one
all that matters now is what edwin diaz
can do here in this bottom of the ninth
inning
in search of a save and now the braves
are down to their final out
ozzy obese will be the better and all
these is all for five
with three strikeouts against diaz and
he lifts one down the left field side
coming over as dom smith and the ball
game is over
just like that couple of fly ball outs
and diaz has the save and the men
snapped their three-game losing streak